et j'ouvre notre second débat vous le
savez le plus souvent possible on
choisit de volontairement le décaler de
l'actualité du jour avec cette question
comment les centrales nucléaires
françaises
vont-elles passer l'été avec le
réchauffement climatique avec les
sécheresses annoncées les réacteurs
manque d'eau avant d'en analyser les
conséquences à court et moyen terme un
premier constat détaillé par Jérôme
le réchauffement climatique va-t-il
remettre en cause le développement du
nucléaire français un comble pour ceux
qui vendent cette énergie comme bonne
pour le climat car où il est 54
réacteurs nucléaires français ont besoin
d'eau et plutôt en grosses quantité et
après un hiver particulièrement sec la
chef de fil des écologistes tire la
sonnette d'alarme à ce rythme il n'y
aura bientôt plus assez d'eau dans nos
fleuves pour refroidir les centrales
nucléaires une accusation récurrente
rejetée par les défenseurs du nucléaire
qui dénonce un catastrophisme des
antiatomes tous les étés dès qu'il fait
un peu chaud on a des communiqués des
Antilles nucléaires pour expliquer que
c'est dramatiques et qu'on pourra rien
faire bon c'est pas une nouveauté
maintenant il faut pas nier qu'il va y
avoir des adaptations nécessaires et
surtout
pensez aux futurs parcs si le débit
nérivières doit baisser de 10 à 40%
comme on l'entend il faudra en prélever
moins et s'assurer que que tout
fonctionne bien plusieurs sites sont
particulièrement sensibles l'an dernier
pendant la longue période de canicule 5
sites ont dû obtenir une dérogation pour
rejeter de l'eau plus chaude que les
seuils prévus dans les cours d'eau qui
les alimentent avec un risque d'impact
sur les écosystèmes deux sites sont
particulièrement problématiques en
raison de cours d'eau au débit menacé
par la sécheresse la centrale de Civaux
sur la Vienne et surtout la centrale de
chaux sur la Meuse à centrale de chaux
sur la Meuse EDF a parfois dû
interrompre la production
d'un ou deux réacteurs à cause de cette
contrainte de débit minimal sur la sur
la Meuse c'est la seule centrale
française qui a dû mettre un scier à
l'arrêt c'est deux réacteurs nucléaires
en raison d'un débit trop faible et d'un
accord international avec la Belgique
voisine mais d'autres centrales ont déjà
du réduire leur puissance pour faire
face à l'allée à climatique
notamment le cas l'an dernier mais le
vrai sujet est sur le long terme la
perte de production n'a pas été très
conséquente pour EDF ça a été seulement
de quelques pourcents pendant une
période assez limitée mais la question
se pose de de l'évolution de cette
tendance à l'échéance de quelques
dizaines d'années la période estivale
n'étant pas la plus tendue pour le
réseau électrique français les
conséquences sont pour l'instant
limitées mais les scénarios les plus
pessimistes de réchauffement climatique
sont désormais scrutés pour adapter le
nucléaire français à cette contrainte je
vous présente tout de suite les invités
du second débat de ce sens public
Nicolas Golberg bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes associés énergie chez Columbus
Daniel et Gabriel bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi sénateurs LRD
Vosges rapporteur du projet de loi sur
la construction des nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires Erwan Benezet bonsoir
bienvenue journaliste au service
économique du Parisien et auteur de ce
livre nucléaire une catastrophe
française publiée aux éditions
Fayard évidemment et qui est resté à mes
côtés il y a les questions du manque
d'eau on va on va en parler on va parler
aussi de ces nouvelles fissures plus
profondes que quand ils étaient
découvertes sur la centrale de Penly qui
qui prolonge rallonge le programme de
contrôle et de réparation ma première
question elle est volontairement
provocatrice Nicolas Goldberg est-ce que
nos centrales nucléaires vont passer
l'été bah évidemment qu'elles vont
passer l'été enfin quand on regarde
l'été dernier effectivement il y a eu
des baisses de puissance assez limitées
sur certaines centrales et d'ailleurs
certaines avaient eu une dérogation mais
toute ne l'ont pas utilisé et quand on
dit est-ce qu'elles vont passer l'été en
fait c'est un peu trompeur parce que le
nucléaire a besoin d'eau pour
fonctionner mais refroidir les réacteurs
pour refroidir les réacteurs qui
fonctionnent par contre un réacteur à
l'arrêt ne consomme quasiment plus d'eau
donc effectivement on peut arrêter les
réacteurs quand il y a des contraintes
de débit quand il y a des contraintes de
température pour des questions de
préservation de la biodiversité mais oui
etc on était pas forcément on était pas
forcément parce que le besoin est
beaucoup plus bas bien évidemment quand
on a eu des grandes opérations
maintenant ce qu'on a eu l'été dernier
en raison des corrosion sous contrainte
là c'est un petit peu plus problématique
mais il faut bien voir que les baisses
de puissance elles sont extrêmement
faibles le besoin est faible aussi en
été donc normalement il y a des marges
ce qui était plus contraignant l'été
dernier c'est les arrêts pour des
questions maintenant pour les
inspections pour les visites des
scénales c'est ça qui est vraiment
structurant dans les arrêts du parcours
avec une question peut-être quand même
Daniel gabier sur sur la question de
l'eau parce qu'on a il y a eu
effectivement les les dérogations
accordées pas forcément utilisé mais
accorder cet été est-ce que le régime
dérogatoire va pas devenir permanent
vous voyez ce que je veux dire non moi
je suis très très rassuré là-dessus
parce que d'abord le régime dérogatoire
il a été vraiment marginal
et d'autant plus que le sujet de
refroidissement je fais confiance au
progrès et il y a plusieurs éléments
d'abord l'Autorité de sûreté à faire un
travail et a déjà alerté et aujourd'hui
EDF et ça a été confirmé par le rapport
de la Cour des comptes qui précise bien
que même eDF n'a pas attendu après
cette je dirais intérêt pour le grand
public du la question climatique pour
prendre un corps le sujet de comment je
vais refroidir de ma vie centrale
d'ailleurs on a deux systèmes on a un
système en circuit quasiment fermé qui
consomme d'ailleurs un peu plus d'eau
que le système où il suffit de faire
passer
repart et même on a eu un cas en 2022 on
peut le citer parce qu'on peut parler
des cas à l'inverse ou l'eau qui
ressortait de la centrale était plus
froide que celle qui rentrait parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a aussi des
technologies qui permettent
effectivement de diminuer et de
refroidir l'eau une fois qu'elle a
refroidi le système
nucléaire et aujourd'hui je non
aujourd'hui vous faites pardon vous
dites je fais confiance au progrès
scientifique pourquoi pas mais mais
l'été qu'on avait vécu l'été dernier là
aussi les scientifiques nous disent que
ça va sans doute devenir la norme dans
les dans les 10 et 20 prochaines années
donc il faut quand même s'y préparer à
ça puisque si on se retrouve à fermer
nos centrales chaque été scientifique il
y a quand même un souci qui tombera
toujours autant d'eau tous les ans sur
notre territoire donc c'est aux
alentours de 500 milliards de mètres
cubes donc sur
CS500 milliards on sera je pense capable
aussi dans stocker de faire en sorte que
cette eau qui tombe ne repartent pas
directement la mer sans être utile à
l'homme y compris à la biodiversité y
compris en termes de production
énergétique non je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il y a des défis ils sont merveilleux
parce que ça nous oblige à prendre des
décisions ça nous oblige à être
courageux mais n'oublions pas que le
double défi que nous avons devant nous
c'est d'avoir aussi une énergie
décarbonée évidemment oui donc
la date mais on est monté très très haut
et on reviendra jamais en arrière donc
pour répondre on retrouvera pas ce
niveau de produits
existant parce que de toute façon ils
vieillit ça ne va pas échappé et on
ferme des on a quand même fermé déjà
deux réacteurs on en refermera peut-être
d'autres c'est pas aux politiques de
décider c'est pas même à nous c'est
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire de
décider si des réacteurs sont viables ou
pas personne d'autre
sauf une décision politique mais dans
ces cas-là faut qu'elle soit assumée
mais donc on ne reviendra jamais à ces à
ces productions puisque le le parc
nucléaire vieillit et c'est même
d'ailleurs la grande question la très
grande question c'est pour ça que je
serai un peu plus circonspect sur la
réponse à votre question tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'on passera l'été oui sans
doute on passera l'été sera un petit peu
compliqué mais c'est pas le moment le
plus tendu est-ce qu'on passera l'hiver
ça va être encore plus compliqué ce
qu'on passera l'hiver prochain pour une
raison c'est que nous sommes tous
aujourd'hui
dans l'attente de la réponse de la SN la
réponse de la SN au programme de de
réparation des réacteurs nucléaires vous
allez on va en parler sur les corrosion
sous contrainte sur sur la fatigue
thermique etc et en fait on est suspendu
à cette décision parce que en fonction
de la décision si jamais finalement la
SN demande à EDF de revoir son
calendrier son chantier en disant bah
non finalement il y a plusieurs gens que
enfin c'est plusieurs gens que ce que
vous disiez il va falloir faire mais
plus de réacteurs là ça devient
compliqué et ça on le saura normalement
on est censé avoir la réponse de la SN
ce mois-ci mois d'avril d'accord alors
on va faire on va on va revenir sur
l'histoire des enfin sur l'histoire sur
la question des fissures de la
profondeur des figure ce qu'on appelle
le je crois le grand carénage
c'est-à-dire c'est le programme de
d'entretien c'est de choses différentes
mais le grand carnet c'est l'entretien
régulier mais évidemment les deux euh
les arrêts liées au grand carénage voilà
maintenant pour pouvoir faire voilà ça
on en parlera un peu plus tard je
voudrais qu'on se concentre sur la
question de l'eau tout de suite et des
quantités d'eau consommée par notre parc
nucléaire alors évidemment il y a eu le
mois de février record en termes de
sécheresse donc à ce moment-là il y a eu
beaucoup de réactions politiques je vous
en propose une première c'est la
secrétaire nationale d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts elle déclare sur Twitter alors
une fois pour toute disons le simplement
est fermement à ce rythme il n'y aura
bientôt plus assez d'eau dans nos
fleuves pour refroidir les centrales
nucléaires bon alors on a cherché à
savoir avoir des chiffres sur l'eau
consommée par nos centrale on voit la 2
la société française d'énergie nucléaire
qui nous dit entre 5 et 10%, le parc
nucléaire utilise entre 5 et 10% de
l'eau consommée en France très bien et
puis alors il y a la source du ministère
de la transition écologique qu'il a
parle de 12% de l'eau consommée en
France
c'est pas le parc nucléaire en fait qui
consomme 12% c'est tout le parc
thermique d'accord en fait c'est toute
la production d'électricité qui consomme
12% et donc c'est pour ça que la société
française de l'énergie nucléaire dit bah
il pas que le parc nucléaire encore un
petit peu de charbon on a encore un
petit peu un petit peu de gaz en fait
des chiffres validé par tout le monde
maintenant ils sont publiés par le
ministère donc on a 12% sur l'ensemble
du parc du parc électrique c'est plutôt
fiable c'est peut-être un peu moins du
coup si on considère juste le parc
nucléaire mais effectivement il y a eu
un quoi que un peu avant parce que la
société française de l'énergie nucléaire
n'avait pas actualisé son chiffre et
disait 20% le ministère disait 31 et
justement tout le monde c'était je suis
en disant mais
31% et 10 ou 12 le chien je sais pas
expliquer pourquoi le chiffre était faux
mais il était faux et du coup il a été
revu et donc là on est à 12% pour vous
donner quelques ordres de grandeur
l'agriculture c'est autour de 60% de
l'eau consommée l'eau potable c'est
environ 20% mais ce qu'il faut dire
aussi c'est que le sujet est très
différencié par centrale parce que une
centrale nucléaire en bord de mer ça ne
consomme pas d'eau on consomme pas d'eau
parce que ça restitue la totalité et les
prochains EPR les quatre premiers en
tout cas on les mettra en bord de mer
justement pour éviter de consommer de
l'eau les diviser suivant ben ça c'est
la question moi j'ai l'impression enfin
quand j'entends le discours c'est très
compliqué sur nucléaire parce que et on
l'a vu avec le tweet là de marine
Tondelier c'est un peu il y a toujours
les pros complètement pro et les contre
complètement contre donc il y a jamais
de discours un peu nuancé et ce qu'on va
celui des rois de bénéziers j'allais
dire c'est que mais c'est très difficile
on peut aussi pour le nucléaire mais
parce qu'on en fait actuellement
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut aussi pointer
les dangers ou en tout cas les
manquements à une technologie
extrêmement pointue extrêmement coûteuse
parfois dangereuse et de se dire il faut
vraiment que ça soit bien cadré pour y
aller et avoir le sentiment que ça ne
l'est pas oui parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a une espèce
d'indulgence environnementale parce que
on sent que c'est une technologie dont
on est fier forcément qui est décarbonée
si on regarde le nucléaire que par le
trou de la lornguette du CO2 ça va si on
élargit un petit peu vous parliez de
l'eau il y a par exemple des problèmes
d'entreposage des déchets radioactifs
quand on manque d'eau ça c'est quand
même une question alors il y a des
réservoirs de recours mais on va pas
pouvoir faire en fait on peut pas avoir
ces dérogations qui qui grossissent
indéfiniment par rapport à certains
indulgence environnementales qu'on a
vis-à-vis du nucléaire parce
qu'évidemment l'argument de choc c'est
le CO2 forcément aucune énergie autre et
on le voit bien en Allemagne on a des
des résultats que ça et je trouve que
c'est intéressant de commencer à avoir
ces nuances de pouvoir parler des
dangers tout en parlant des avantages du
nucléaire est-ce qu'on peut je leur
donne la parole juste après est-ce que
est-ce que finalement on j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a jamais réussi
depuis au moins 30 ans à avoir un regard
plus scientifique ou technique sur le
notre épargne nucléaire que politique
c'est toujours un c'est toujours des
présupposés idéologiques ou politiques
qui ont qui ont guidé les décisions des
des gouvernement est-ce que vous dites
ça non je dis pas ça parce que je pense
que la situation il y a
il y a 30 ans et très très différente en
termes climatique de celle que l'on vit
aujourd'hui même si on a connu et je le
dis j'en parle en connaissance de cause
je suis paysan et je me suis installé à
l'année la sécheresse 75 donc j'ai vécu
76 76 qui a été terrible donc si on
reprend du temps ça veut dire qu'il y a
50 ans effectivement il y a eu aussi des
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation plus répétitive qui est la
fréquence elle se succède pour le paysan
que je suis
ce que m'a transmis mon père c'est que
on est aussi dans en une autre
climatique on a des cycles et c'est pour
ça que je j'explique à mes enfants
continuer d'enterrer vos conduites d'eau
à 80 mètres de profondeur parce que moi
j'ai connu la terre je l'ai 1m20 donc
peut-être que ça recommencera aussi il y
aura aussi pour revenir sur le dossier
du nucléaire je crois que vous savez sur
le nucléaire
quand je vois les avancées qu'il y a eu
et les avancées technologiques
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs dans le en
tant que rapporteur le Sénat dans le ce
que nous avons voté nous sommes en
pleine discussion avec ma collègue de
l'Assemblée pour la CMP du début de mai
nous avons renforcé la sécurité et sur
les futurs acteurs sur les nouveaux bien
sûr oui mais il faut embrasser et
aujourd'hui la SN et EDF travail y
compris sur les réacteurs actuels on
aura je suis persuadé des technologies
qui nous permettront effectivement de
refroidir l'eau le dossier de de l'eau
par rapport à aux fournitures
électriques en Allemagne ou on est sur
du charbon on est sur du gaz on a besoin
d'eux aussi donc et il faut faire une
différence entre les mètres cubes d'eau
qui passent pour refroidir et qui ne
font que transiter quelques secondes
dans la centrale et qui retrouve
quelques centaines de mètres le cours
d'eau aussitôt donc là on est on n'est
pas sur un prélèvement on est sur un
problème de
éventuellement d'une évolution de
température si le cours d'eau est
lui-même déjà à des niveaux très donc il
y a effectivement cette capacité des
conséquences sur la biodiversité quand
même l'eau
sur la biodiversité il y a une étude de
des agences qui est très précise il y a
eu aucune conséquence sur la
biodiversité qui n'a été observée
tellement le l'influence de
l'augmentation de température est un
film donc au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est la
situation d'aujourd'hui c'est pas pour
autant qu'il faut pas se poser la
question et je rejoins votre votre
propos c'est dire aujourd'hui on a un
défi climatique qui doit être comme on a
un défi sur la cybersécurité moi je
l'entends que rapporteur et le Sénat
vraiment inciter l'astu nous l'avons
renforcé la SN ça fait partie
effectivement de toutes ces exigences
qu'elle a aujourd'hui par rapport à EDF
et EDF c'est même la Cour des comptes
qu'il le dit
a déjà avant même que des cette attente
a fait des investissements sur le
dossier de refroidissement c'est un
sujet mais le sujet je suis encore là
encore dans c'est mon côté optimiste
parce que le pire ce ne serait pas en
parler ne pas en parler effectivement
mais dès lors qu'on en parle ça fera
partie des exigences alors le futur part
il y a plusieurs personnes qui veulent
Emilie pour commencer ensuite je vous
donne la parole moi je trouve ça génial
qu'on puisse parler de tout ça mais
c'est un peu dans un dans le merveilleux
monde du nucléaire parce que sur la
technologie on voit qu'on a du mal quand
même à avancer sur ces fameux futurs EPR
si j'ai bien compris les fissures elles
sont pas forcément sur les plus
anciennes centrales ça vient aussi sur
des centrales récentes donc moi je
questionne plus notre capacité
technologique et on sait que au niveau
des compétences on a un peu perdu aussi
à construire des centrales qui tiennent
compte de se réchauffement climatique
qui tiennent compte de ces problèmes
qu'on a desrosions de corrosion et de
fissures je suis enfin voilà après
peut-être qu'on y arrivera mais on n'en
sait rien finalement ouais on y
reviendra un peu plus tard dans le débat
si vous voulez bien parce que la
question et puis la question des
recrutes j'ai recrutement du nombre
d'ingénieurs du nombre de d'ouvriers
ultra spécialisés qu'il faut recruter
pas on n'est pas d'accord sur les
chiffres on est en 2023 comment c'est
possible et donc parce que justement la
parole scientifique n'est pas
suffisamment mise en avant et c'est de
la parole politique qui en plus n'arrête
pas de changer on a eu l'hiver nucléaire
2010 2020 et aujourd'hui c'est le grand
retour nucléaire très bien pourquoi pas
mais posons les faits sur la table juste
un un petit point sur la parole
scientifique le gouvernement a voulu
réunir l'IRSN et l'ASN donc réduire le
champ entre le contrôle et entre les
prises de décision et entre l'étude
scientifique c'est un problème voilà on
n'avance pas sur la parole scientifique
et ça se fait au détriment d'une parole
politique qui n'est pas toujours très
éclairée alors je vous propose on va
voir tout de suite avec Quentin Calmet
sur quels exemples européens de quels
exemples européens on pourrait
s'inspirer pour quand vous rentrez j'ai
juste un son avancer mais installez-vous
vous êtes le bienvenu vous avez un essai
mais c'est moi c'est mon lancement qui
est à l'envers je voudrais quand même
qu'on entende un exemple tient de de
solution pour poser à l'étranger qui
nous est donné par Christine lavard de
la sénatrice des Hauts-de-Seine
rapporteur lors des auditions menées par
la commission des finances ici au Sénat
sur l'adaptation de nos centrales aux
conséquences du changement climatique on
l'écoute c'était il y a trois semaines
Christine Labarde
la gestion et de la ressource en eau
elle ouvre aussi un nouveau champ
d'interrogation qui surgit là en ce
moment on voit bien que nos nappes
phréatiques commencent à être un niveau
très bas qui est celui de la
réutilisation des eaux usées qui
aujourd'hui est proche de zéro en France
et typiquement le fonctionnement de la
centrale de Palo Verde qui est bien
décrite dans le rapport on voit qu'on
c'est une Centrale qui se refroidit en
utilisant les eaux usées alors après ça
nécessitait tout un une infrastructure
et ce qu'aujourd'hui nous on est prêt à
avoir des canalisations très longues
pour venir on n'est pas dans le même
contexte là on a une Centrale qui est
dans le désert aujourd'hui à aucun
endroit en France en tout cas qui
pourrait avoir mais ça ouvre quand même
des perspectives sur aussi une autre
utilisation possible des eaux usées
et donc on retrouve Quentin calmé pour
nous parler de ses alternatives ces
solutions alternatives de
refroidissement des centrales nucléaires
voilà qui viennent d'un peu d'être
évoqués effectivement par la sénatrice
l'avare en France on l'a dit il faut le
répéter toutes les centrales sont
unplantées à côté d'un cours d'eau ou
près de la mer et de l'océan elles sont
peu nombreuses mais il y a dans le monde
quelques centrales dont le modèle
diffère et donc celle la plus connue de
la centrale de Palo Verde qui est situé
c'est vrai dans le désert d'Arizona aux
États-Unis c'est le plus gros site
producteur d'électricité aux États-Unis
alors il y a pas de tour de
refroidissement vous voyez il y a pas
ces grandes tours qu'on voit en France
par exemple mais on voit tout autour
d'immense bassins il s'agit des eaux
usées de la ville de Phoenix qui se
trouve à 70 km de là ce sont des
millions de mètres cubes d'eau qui sont
donc recyclés cette eau vient de la
ville via les bassins de traitement de
l'eau mais il y a un souci il y a une
concurrence autour de cette ressource en
eau voilà ce n'est pas un modèle parfait
en ça peut être parce que face à la
pénurie en eau la demande pour les eaux
usées et devenu très élevés également en
Arizona pour l'irrigation par exemple le
prix de cette eau usé a été multiplié
par 6 depuis 2010 donc la problématique
c'est l'accès à la ressource en eau et
pas seulement ou pas forcément la
température extérieure c'est ça
exactement puisqu'on en revient à l'idée
qu'on peut effectivement avoir les
centrales nucléaires dans le désert il
est possible d'exploiter une centrale
même par 52 degrés Celsius à l'extérieur
et une eau de mer qui même serait à 35
degrés utilisé pour refroidir les
turbines la preuve avec un dernier
exemple que je voulais évoquer depuis
avril 2021 les Émirats arabes unis
disposent d'une centrale nucléaire vous
la voyez celle de baraka c'est la seule
pour l'heure parmi les pays arabes
lorsqu'ils seront pleinement
opérationnels les quatre réacteurs de
cette centrale produiront 5600 MW sans
environ 25% des besoins en électricité
du pays la solution vient de super
condenseur pour refroidir l'eau toute
l'importance et donc bien l'accès à
l'autre merci Quentin pour ces
explications Nicolas Golder alors on est
on a on n'est pas au milieu du désert en
France on a une ressource en nous on est
plutôt Bénin et Dieu depuis des
décennies même si on voit bien que il
faut se tourner vers les exemples de de
pays du Sud où il habitude de d'être
face à des notamment dans la gestion des
eaux usées certes on n'est pas dans le
désert mais on pourrait effectivement
refroidir nos centrales avec des eaux
usées pourquoi on fait pas c'est plus
compliqué ça demande plus de
canalisations derrière vous avez des
accès concurrents à l'OE usée ça va
aussi dépendre de la consommation de la
ville de Phoenix si la ville de Phoenix
se met à consommer moins d'eau est-ce
qu'il y aura forcément moins d'eau
usés pour la centrale donc il y a cet
accès concurrent et surtout en France on
a quelque chose qui est plutôt bien ça
s'appelle la mère à côté donc on a 14
réacteurs qui sont déployés en bord de
mer et donc l'eau qui prélève dans
l'océan ça rentre dans les chiffres de
prélèvement d'eau mais en deux mais au
bord de la mer il y a pas un accès
concurrent à l'eau et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que les premiers EPS qu'on va
déployer les quatre premiers ils vont
être plutôt en bord de mer la question
c'est les 10 suivants où est-ce qu'on
les met et du coup comment est-ce qu'on
va adapter les systèmes il faut bien
dire que quand vous avez une tour à
héros réfrigérateur il y a certains
sujets de consommation d'eau mais vous
en prélevez moins aussi sur le fleuve
donc vous êtes moins sujet aux arrêts
pendant l'été parce que il y a un sujet
de débit et enfin on a parlé de la
centrale de Palo Verde effectivement en
Arizona il y a des centrales nucléaires
en Afrique du Sud qui sont refroidis
sans tour aéro réfrigérantes avec un
système d'échangeur enfin d'échangeur
thermique qui sont en gros des gros
radiateurs qui permettent de dissiper la
chaleur dans l'air mais sans faire de
trop de prélèvements d'eau donc il y a
des technologies qui existent là pour le
design dans le PR2 c'est peut-être un
petit peu tard mais on pourra on pourra
adapter et il faut bien dire quelque
chose c'est que 14 EPR c'est pas les 56
qu'on a aujourd'hui donc si on dit que
on va avoir des réacteurs qui seront
plus puissants plutôt en bord de mer
moins en bord de fleuve et bien
finalement on pourrait même en
construisant des réacteurs nucléaires
évoluer vers une situation où on
prélèverait moins d'eau alors c'est
justement la question que j'allais vous
poser Daniel grimier c'est nouveau
réacteur voilà est-ce qu'ils sont sur le
modèle dans leur
utilisation de la ressource en eau des
précédents ou est-ce que ils ont intégré
des nouvelles solutions comme celle dont
on parlait avec les eaux usées par
exemple et ça ça fait partie de du
cahier des charges nouveau et des
exigences de la SN et les exigences
elles vont être croissantes au fur et à
mesure des années c'est pour ça que je
oui mais les réacteurs c'est aujourd'hui
qu'on les qu'on les conçoit et c'est
demain qu'on va les construire donc les
solutions faut les on va pas les
transformer dans cinq ans vous voyez ce
que je veux dire je parle donc si on dit
si on y pardon je peux moi je pose des
questions basiques volontairement si on
décide d'utiliser les eaux usées je
reste sur cet exemple qui simple et qui
parle à tout le monde c'est aujourd'hui
qu'il faut prendre cette décision
technologique ou est-ce que c'est déjà
trop tard est-ce que de toute façon
comme vous nous dites les plans sont les
plans sont faits et on est sur une
solution plus ancienne je peux
volontairement la question parce que
aujourd'hui les centrales enfin
directeurs qui vont être construits ne
seront pas construites construits sur
les bases des anciennes et la
problématique est encore une fois je dis
l'exigence de la SN et je suis pas
d'accord avec vous lorsque vous parlez
du politique je veux dire pourquoi en
tant que rapporteur
je suis pas scientifique
j'ai besoin du scientifique d'une
expertise scientifique vraiment pointue
nous avons la chance en France de
l'avoir il appartient après au politique
de prendre ses décisions en connaissance
du chien par exemple
permettez-moi d'aller vous donc
j'insiste là dessus parce que le dossier
de l'énergie c'est un dossier
stratégique pour nos concitoyens nos
collectivités notre économie je suis
désolé pour vivre il faut que l'assiette
soit remplie et il faut l'énergie sinon
il y a pas envie donc c'est un enjeu
ayant d'ailleurs on se rend bien compte
avec des débats qu'on a à l'heure
actuelle au niveau communautaire entre
l'Allemagne et la France ils ont tout
compris les Allemands les certains pays
ont compris
le nucléaire a été une chance
énergétique pour nos concitoyens notre
économie aujourd'hui il y a quand même
eu des décisions parlons nous
interrompre qui était purement politique
quand François Hollande signale un
accord avec les verbes bah non mais
dictent de faire passer le dans les
années 90 ne mélangeons pas
pour une raison de sûreté ouais je parle
mais mais comme ceux qui ont décidé que
le parc nucléaire serait plus qu'à 50%
euh c'est la c'est la même chose je vous
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui on est quand
même quasiment encore à 70% d'énergie
qui proviennent
d'énergie électrique qui provient d'une
nucléaire
oui en 2022 avec les problèmes que avec
les problèmes on a jamais connu mais en
terme de de pourcentage ça reste
considérable bon mais donc les
politiques prennent parfois des
décisions qui sont purement
spectateur je voudrais pas qu'il y a on
rentre dans la confusion c'est comme le
dossier de l'eau entre l'eau que j'ai
besoin pour refroidir et l'eau qui passe
uniquement pour refroidir qui retourne
dans le cours d'eau le fleuve ça n'a
rien à voir avec de l'eau qui part en
évaporation encore quand elle part en
évaporation elle retombe pour une grande
partie elle retombe d'ailleurs donc mais
là quand vous faites le le vous menez le
débat entre le dossier du politique qui
prend comme l'a fait hollande président
Hollande effectivement et qui est pour
moi une faute grave pour des raisons
politiques mais pas pour des raisons de
sécurité moi je en tant qu'élu en tant
que rapporteur et le travail que j'ai
fait et que le positionnement du Sénat
sur le sujet du nucléaire c'est de dire
nous avons besoin d'une autorité de
sécurité nucléaire qui soit complètement
libre qui est la responsabilité vraiment
et avec les enjeux et d'ailleurs c'est
des questions je lui pose dans mon
rapport dans ce qui a été voté le texte
de loi qui a été voté au Sénat et
demande à l'autorité de renforcer encore
le sujet de la résilience par rapport au
problème de l'évolution climatique de la
cybersécurité c'est le rôle du politique
mais après ne mélangeons pas à la
sécurité du choix ensuite pour en
préparer tout à l'heure du des énergies
renouvelables sur le le
géographiquement c'est nouveau réacteurs
dont on parle donc vous nous dites ils
vont être prioritairement placé en bord
les quatre les quatre premiers
on a quand même l'impression qu'on a
toujours un peu un temps de retard vous
lisiez le mieux serait de positionner
les nouveaux réacteurs au bord de la mer
les deux les deux premières paires ça
sera le cas la première à panique
pourquoi pas libre parce que le site
existe en deux pays construire le Pr qui
a été finalement construit à Flamanville
il y a le terrain on peut le faire
ensuite à Gravelines la centrale au nord
une des plus grandes plus puissantes en
Europe et puis après la troisième paire
mais pour l'instant qu'est-ce qui est
prévu c'est de l'installer au bord du
Rhône va dans la vallée du Rhône on
hésite entre encore entre deux sites
mais donc ça serait au bord d'une
rivière un peu étrange quand même déjà
on se rend compte que aujourd'hui les
sites les plus intéressants ça sera au
bord de la mer et on fait déjà un soin
scientifique un peu bizarre comme celui
d'avoir entreposé les déchets nucléaires
à la Hague qui est qui était un marais
pour quoi l'avoir fait là-bas là encore
peut-être sans doute un choix un choix
politique et non pas scientifique bref
on a toujours un peu un temps de retard
ce qui est un peu étrange aussi dans le
nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est
moi j'ai l'impression à chaque fois
qu'on adapte l'environnement au lieu de
s'adapter à l'environnement certes on
peut installer une centrale nucléaire à
peu près partout dans le monde y compris
au fin fond du désert il y aura toujours
une solution technologique sera-t-elle
viable économiquement c'est moins sûr et
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que oui on
peut adapter oui on pourrait refroidir
nos réacteurs en utilisant bien moins
d'eau y compris les réacteurs existants
et ça coûterait une fortune et ça va
encore coûter une fortune et là c'est le
premier c'est un peu comme les méga
bastines c'est à dire que on s'adapte on
s'adapte l'environnement pour un système
productif et c'est la même problème avec
l'énergie ça sera encore de la
production plutôt de que nous mettre
l'accent notamment par exemple sur la
sobriété alors vous parliez d'argent le
coût de construction estimé
j'insiste sur le terme pour les les
futurs réacteurs européennes on est à
près de 52 milliards d'euros c'est EDF
qui nous dit ça ils doivent sortir de
terre entre 2035 et 2050 je dis estimé
parce que c'est susceptible d'évoluer le
chantier de Flamanville nous a rendu
prudent évidemment Émilie sur tous ces
projets de nouvelles réacteurs ce qui
vous a intéressé c'est que vous nous
dites ça s'est fait sans réel débat
public oui parce qu'elle a on voit bien
que là toutes ces questions autour des
centrales nucléaires la sécheresse le
réchauffement climatique ça fait
toujours des bas mais par contre sur la
question du retour au tout nucléaire en
France ça s'est fait de manière assez
rapide un retour qui qui semble pour une
fois acté enfin pour une fois pour toute
actée et le tout en effet sans trop de
débat public ou en tout cas en ne tenant
pas trop compte du débat public alors
cette énergie et on l'a dit elle répond
aux enjeux actuels de souveraineté
énergétique et puis aussi de réduction
de nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc très bien ça a été fortement mis en
valeur pendant la période covid avec la
guerre en Ukraine on voit bien que ça
nous sort du jeu et en quelque sorte
après ces événements et ben on est tous
devenus pro-nucléaire et notre président
le premier alors qu'au départ il était
pas si convaincu par le nucléaire le 10
février 2022 une très belle fort il fait
un discours en décrétant que la
renaissance du nucléaire français et le
chantier du siècle objectif construire
ces fameux nouveau réacteurs dont vous
avez dit que en effet certains devraient
commencer à être mis en service dès 2035
et donc cette question du débat public
est-ce que le gouvernement a fait la
place à un débat public alors oui il y
avait la place pour se débat qui était
organisé par la Commission nationale du
débat public la CNDP ça commençait à
l'automne 2022 pour réfléchir jusqu'en
février 2023 donc juste là aux
conditions de la relance de ce programme
nucléaire aux enjeux de sûreté aux
conséquences en matière d'environnement
local mais alors c'était sans compter la
rapidité du gouvernement en termes de
décision puisque dans un amendement au
projet de loi justement dont on parlait
sur le nucléaire qui a été adopté par le
Sénat et par l'Assemblée en première
lecture il a supprimé le plafond de 50%
du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité d'ici 2035 on l'a dit tout
à l'heure c'était un objectif qui avait
été fixé par François Hollande direction
de cette Commission nationale du débat
public elle a pas du tout apprécié et
elle a pas tardé à faire connaître sa
réaction dans un comité officiel de sa
présidente Chantal Jouanno alors c'était
le 18 janvier 2023 une telle mesure
anticipant de quelques mois un débat
relevant du projet de loi de
programmation énergétique ne change rien
au délai de réalisation éventuelle d'un
programme de relance du nucléaire elle
revient en revanche a considérer comme
sans intérêt pour définir la stratégie
énergétique les interrogations les
remarques et les propositions faites
lors du débat public en cours qu'a fait
Chantal Jouanno escala abandonné
justement ce débat alors une partie des
réunions ont été annulées et ensuite le
débat a été recentré sur un tout nouveau
thème en tout cas un thème différent
puisque là il s'agissait de voir la
place du public dans la gouvernance de
la politique nucléaire on voit bien que
ça a quand même beaucoup évolué alors on
pourrait se dire et par rapport à ce
qu'on se disait tout à l'heure que c'est
quand même bien l'idée de se poser de
réfléchir avant de se lancer tête
baissée dans le nucléaire surtout quand
on voit moi je suis pas d'accord avec le
solucléaire mais en or ben non il y a
beau il y a le développement des
énergies renouvelables en même temps
alors pour une partie du nucléaire avec
le plafond des 50 % qui ont sauté on va
dire ça on voit que d'autres pays ont
d'autres trajectoires et puis on voit
qu'il y a des risques quand même qui
persistent sur nucléaire et moi ça somme
importe aussi d'en parler j'ai regardé
juste justement les rapports de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et
vraiment en feuilletant très rapidement
je suis tombé sur un accident notamment
qui était cité qui date de décembre 2022
et tout simplement il s'agissait de
l'évacuation accidentelle donc de
déchets nucléaire contaminés dans le
circuit de collecte des ordures
ménageurs je dis pas où pas de stress de
toute façon c'est indiqué de toute façon
c'est bilans sont complètement public
mais c'est vrai que voilà c'est des
petites choses qui peuvent quand même se
mettre la puce à l'oreille de se dire
que de voir la totalité du nucléaire les
déchets les fissures on en a parlé les
risques si vous en parliez cybersécurité
est plus globalement de sécurité dans un
contexte mondial qui est quand même
assez fracturé assez difficile avec les
guerres qu'on connaît c'est un peu la
face du cacher du nucléaire que l'on
préfère ne pas voir dans les temps qui
courent faire vite pour ne pas trop
réfléchir pour des choix qui pourtant
même si c'est pas du tout nucléaire vont
nous impacter pendant les 100 prochaines
années bon au-delà du terme tout
nucléaire effectivement moi je trouve
que c'est un vrai débat merci beaucoup
Emilie intéressant sur le l'absence ou
non de débat public il y a un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat
évidemment bon mais quand même cette
commission nationale de réplique elle
est là pour ça pour pour donner la
parole à des citoyens avant avant un
choix aussi important
je le dis d'autant plus que
effectivement le texte il est arrivé en
premier au Sénat et c'est votre
serviteur c'est moi-même qui est déposé
l'amendement sur à la fois le 63,2
gigawatts etc pas tellement le
gouvernement pas du tout parce qu'il
était même contre il était contre donc
et ensuite et je suis heureux de voir
que l'Assemblée nationale c'était
complètement repris
je voudrais revenir quand même sur le
débat public mon propos au Sénat j'ai
commencé par dire je suis je regrette
qu'on n'est pas laissé le temps au débat
public avant de l'examiner au Sénat
d'autant plus qu'on avait le temps de le
respecter ce temps contenu du décalage
qui a eu entre l'examen à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat je vous rappelle
quand même que c'est le gouvernement qui
fait l'ordre du jour du Parlement et
autres remarques on a un voté un texte
sur les honneurs on vote un texte sur la
loi d'accélération son nucléaire alors
qu'on a PPE enfin la loi de
programmation le mix énergétique du
futur on a encore pas et oui on l'a
dites le débat le débat
tout fait à l'envers et je reviens sur
le débat public dans le texte et le
travail que j'ai fait au Sénat qui est
dans le texte voté j'ai renforcé la
transparence la transparence et qui est
la place du débat public dans le qu'on
fasse les choses dans l'ordre je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous mais dès
lors que lors du jour fait que benjama
du texte arrive au Sénat et je ne
comprends pas tout en restant correct et
poli vis-à-vis de la présidente du débat
public je suis désolé mais dès lors que
les parlementaires avaient ce sujet
Isabelle droit aussi de débattre on
pouvait pas leur enlever la capacité de
débattre c'est le responsabilité donc on
l'a fait si j'assume et l'ensemble des
sénatrices des sénateurs ont assumé
cette responsabilité même si on regrette
le calendrier et je voudrais terminer
là-dessus parce que il est vraiment
important redonner la transparence
laissez la place au débat de donner la
place aussi aux collectivités le rôle
des collectivités parce que c'est un
sujet qui concerne tout le monde et
l'enjeu énergétique c'est un enjeu
absolument partagé je reprends
l'améliorer 5 minutes ça passe trop vite
mais ça veut dire que le débat était
passionnant je voudrais qu'on revienne
sur la question des de des capacités de
notre parc nucléaire et c'est lié aux
fissures Agnès peniors ministre de la
transition énergétique annoncé samedi au
journal Le Monde c'est Roady ce mardi
dans une dépêche de l'agence France
Presse avoir demandé à EDF de mettre à
l'étude une augmentation de la puissance
du parc nucléaire français
Erwan denizet
moi j'ai lu ça je me suis dit très bien
mais comment faire alors que on a des
problèmes de fissure et que il faut
contrôler tout ou partie du parc
nucléaire c'est mettre la charrue avant
les bœufs encore une fois c'est faire
des déclarations des demandes des
injonctions sans forcément tenir compte
de la réalité du terrain encore une fois
je lisais tout à l'heure on est tous
suspendus à une décision de l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire sur le calendrier
des réparations du parc nucléaire on
peut demander ce qu'on veut à EDF mais à
un moment aussi une centrale nucléaire
fonctionne on peut lui demander un
surcroît de puissance parce que c'est ce
que j'entends moi dans la demande de
Nicolas alors Nicolas
il y a aujourd'hui le le taux de
disponibilité du parc nucléaire français
ne fait que baisser et bien
inférieur par exemple à celui de des
États-Unis et donc ce qu'on veut
demander c'est que notre parc nucléaire
soit plus efficient mais c'est pas une
question forcément que de volonté c'est
une question technique alors à Nicolas
la réponse c'est que oui on peut le
faire il y a deux choses qu'on peut
faire c'est qu'on peut augmenter la
puissance unitaire des réacteurs et
d'ailleurs ça a été fait aux États-Unis
et ensuite un réacteur normalement on
l'arrête tous les 12 mois on peut les
arrêter tous les 18 mois tous les 24
mois les États-Unis sont passés sur des
campagnes de 24 mois c'est à dire qu'ils
arrêtent leur acteur tous les deux ans
et pas tous les ans pour les recharger
en combustible et ça ça augmente le
productible nucléaire ce qu'il faut dire
toutefois c'est que même si on relance
14 EPR comme c'est le plan et la
décision n'a pas encore été prise
c'est-à-dire qu'on a fait des
simplifications administratives on a
fait des simplifications administratives
sur les énergies renouvelables il faut
le dire la puissance éolienne et solaire
qu'on a déployé l'an dernier c'est
l'équivalent de la puissance de 3 EPR
donc on n'est pas parti sur un tout
nucléaire même si on fait 14 EPR les
réacteurs fermeront plus vite que ce
qu'on est capable de les construire
attendez je vais finir je vais finir par
rapport à l'Allemagne qui a fermé ses
réacteurs et qui a gardé son je vais
juste finir là-dessus si on relance 14
EPR on aura moins de nucléaire que ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui même en puissance
absolue parce que les réacteurs
nucléaires vont fermer plus vite que ce
qu'on est capable de les construire et
on déploie en France aujourd'hui
énormément de renouvelables on déploie
l'équivalent de la puissance de 3R
chaque année et ça va augmenter donc moi
je pense pas qu'on puisse dire qu'on est
parti sur un tour sur un taux nucléaire
quand bien même on prendrait certaines
simplifications administratives pour
aller plus vite sur les projets
Nicolas c'est que d'une part le
l'injonction de Daniel pagne rue naché
elle est très étrange est-ce que ça
voudrait dire que EDF ne fait pas tout
pour utiliser au maximum ces réacteurs
j'espère que la réponse c'est elle fait
tout ce qui lui est techniquement
possible parce que si c'est par exemple
une question de marché si par exemple à
certains moments ça coûte moins cher
d'acheter de de mégawatt-heure sur des
marchés plutôt que de faire produire à
fond les nucléaires là ça serait ça
serait un autre problème j'espère que ça
n'est pas le cas mais ce qui veut dire
que l'injonction d'un Espagnol dans ces
cas-là elle ne sert à rien parce que
c'est d'abord une question une réponse
technique et aujourd'hui EDF pour
l'instant n'est pas en capacité de
demander à ses réacteurs de produire
plus qu'il ne produisent Daniel grimmiel
on va terminer là-dessus l'enjeu majeur
aussi il faut quand on fait un débat
nucléaires il faut en parler c'est
l'enjeu du recrutement des talents pour
pour tenir les objectifs des des
20 prochaines années c'est majeur
écoutez c'est le grand défi parce que
j'aurais quand même en peu de temps
pendant qu'on a ce débat en Allemagne il
se pose pas de question il construisent
de nouvelles centrales au gaz donc je
rappelle que l'objectif par rapport au
sujet de mots par rapport à l'évolution
climatique c'est quand même la
décarbonation et c'est la neutralité
carbone je reviens sur les besoins main
d'oeuvre effectivement en intelligence
et vous n'aurez pas d'entreprises vous
n'aurez pas de jeunesse qui va
s'investir dans un métier si vous êtes
dans un pays qui doute si vous avez une
ligne directrice qui dit oui on va y
aller oui effectivement des perspectives
et effectivement le débat des six
réacteurs c'est pas la réponse c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait cet amendement et
que le Sénat a donné une autre ambition
et les 14 on sait tous parce que même si
on est on fait des efforts énormes en
termes de sobriété énergétique en termes
de d'isolation on sait tous
qu'aujourd'hui la fin du fossile va
nécessiter bien plus d'énergie
électrique c'est ça va être une
obligation et moi je préfère avoir une
énergie électronique
pilotable et il faut pas en poser les
renouvelables avec
l'hydroélectricité et avec on termine
là-dessus merci beaucoup
Erwan Benezet je rappelle le titre de
votre livre rapidement nucléaire une
catastrophe française c'est publié aux
éditions Fayard fin de ce sens public je
vous donne rendez-vous demain 18h 22h et
puis notez que l'ancien ministre brise
sorte que vous avez gagné un lecteur
Brice of feu conseiller régional
Auvergne et Rhône-Alpes c'est un invité
de la matinale demain matin à 8h salut
[Musique]